[Música]
muy buenas tardes buenas tardes a todos
este mi nombre es pavel games tengo 26
años nací y crecí en nuevo laredo
tamaulipas y fui parte del ballet
folklórico de méxico de amalia hernández
por 4 años
antes de empezar a contar un poquito de
mi historia quiero agradecer a los dos
pilares que fueron muy importantes en mi
camino en la danza que sin su apoyo yo
la verdad no hubiera llegado tan lejos y
hasta este momento son mis papás los
profesores pedro gamez muñiz y patricia
guerrero sánchez que están sentados es
un aplauso por favor
[Música]
[Aplausos]
bueno hasta antes de subir a las
escaleras me di cuenta de que soy el
único vestido como vaquero
no me dedico a esto
pero en fin representa a nuestro hermoso
folklore de del norte aquí en tamaulipas
mi camino por la danza empieza desde muy
pequeño
de hecho la razón por la que estos
piecitos se mueven al ritmo de la música
tienen nombre y apellido y es la
anteriormente mencionada la maestra para
ti mi mamá recuerdo el momento exacto en
el que mi cuerpo sintió esa necesidad de
bailar y de estar en un escenario y fue
cuando vi a mi mamá parada en un
escenario experimentando esa sensación
de tener al mundo cautivado mi mamá
abanicándose con un abanico negro con un
hermoso vestido blanco de organza del
maravilloso estado de veracruz méjico
desde ese momento fue un caso perdido
estuve en todos los festivales de danza
que podía desde muy pequeño y no se
digiera de alguien que tuviera un
micrófono y dijera vamos a tener un
concurso de baile porque yo era el
primero en estar arriba del escenario
listo para demostrar lo que yo tenía
tuve la fortuna de bueno primero contar
con el apoyo de mis papás y segundo el
estar en muchas escuelas en donde era
importante el arte para el desarrollo
integral de sus alumnos
fue hasta la preparatoria cuando me
decidió integrar al grupo de danza de la
preparatoria royal aquí en la ciudad de
nuevo laredo bajo la dirección de mi
gran maestro mario cárdenas que en paz
descanse
perdón
que conozco el trabajo tan importante de
la gran amalia hernández y como muchas
personas quedé cautivado por la
complejidad de sus
coreografías y la belleza de las mismas
los vestuarios la escenografía y por
supuesto el talento de sus hermosos
bailarines que estaban en escena
entregándolo todo y llevando la bandera
de méxico internacionalmente
para mí era un sueño de cama era un
sueño que yo jamás pensé alcanzar era
tan era tan lejano que ni siquiera
estaba en mis objetivos de vida
fue hasta que el ballet vino a nuevo
laredo en un festival cultural aquí
justamente al centro cultural de nuevo
laredo cuando yo los veo bailar en vivo
por primera vez y mi cerebro cambia un
switch en el que ya dejó de ser un sueño
inalcanzable y fue un yo quiero yo puedo
me va a costar mucho trabajo pero yo
puedo bailar ahí yo puedo estar ahí con
todos esos bailarines
al finalizar la función me fui con un me
encontré con una tía y ahora permitía
marcela
muy argumentarán
este y le digo sa es que ya quiero ir a
tras bambalinas quiero que me vean
quiero ver si tengo la posibilidad yo
tenía como 17 años vamos a tras
bambalinas tuve un encuentro muy breve
con el coordinador de la compañía con
algunos bailarines le comenté de mis
ganas de pertenecer al ballet me hizo
dar unos pasitos aquí en el lobby del
centro cultural y me dice estás bien
pero tienes que irte a vivir en la
ciudad de mexico a mi corta edad yo
sabía que yo no estaba preparado
decidido de manera personal
al acabar una carrera profesional y
tener un plan b que me permitiera
disfrutar al máximo mi plan a
termino soy licenciado en mercadotecnia
publicidad y eran tantas mis ganas de
bailar que de hecho todos mis maestros
sabían de mis ganas intensas de bailar
todos los maestros sabían que yo al
terminar mi carrera iba a ir a ballet de
amalia hernández hacer mi audición lo
repetía tantas veces a presentar a la
oportunidad porque era algo que tenía
que repetirme a mí mismo para no
y descansar de la idea que me tenía que
seguir esforzando para alcanzar el
objetivo final
en fin eran tantas mis ganas que el día
6 de marzo yo hago y aprueba el examen
profesional el día 11 de marzo yo tenía
mayas pues estás haciendo mi audición
para el ballet folclórico de méxico
corte a cinco meses después me dan
contrato de la compañía esto es porque
hay un tiempo de preparación en la misma
me dan contrato en la compañía y lo
demás fue historia durante mi tiempo en
la compañía tuve la oportunidad de hacer
cosas que jamás imaginé que iba a ser
primero bailar en el palacio de bellas
artes el teatro más importante de méxico
tres días a la semana era mi casa
nosotros llegábamos incluso en
calcetines por los pasillos todos nos
conocían el velador hola cómo está y
todo el mundo se hizo algo tan ordinario
que en mi cabeza perdió la grandeza es
decir cuando yo regresaba me daba cuenta
de que estoy viviendo mi sueño el sueño
más grande lo estoy viviendo en tiempo
real era increíble
baile en el auditorio nacional en
repetidas ocasiones
y baile alrededor de la república en
muchos auditorios muy importantes
también tuve la oportunidad de hacer
varias cosas que la verdad hasta este
momento no me las creo recibía el papa
en su visita a mexico
y una anécdota que les puedo contar que
tal vez es muy graciosa baile
un programa televisivo matutino el cual
no voy a decir el nombre de una
televisora muy importante muy popular a
nivel nacional
que mi mamá y mis tías disfrutan mucho y
todos los días lo ven
y fue para mí algo muy importante estar
en el estudio estado comunicándonos con
mi mamá en cinco minutos salgo en dos
minutos salgo a prender la televisión
que no se vaya la señal etcétera fue
increíble
gracias a un arduo trabajo tuve la
oportunidad de hacer un par de solistas
en la compañía mi crecimiento fue
bastante
bueno y la verdad siempre estaré muy
agradecido por dios y mis padres de
permitirme esa experiencia en la vida
esta anécdota se las comparto a todos
ustedes porque me gustaría motivar a
todos aquellos que tienen una meta tan
grande que parece inalcanzable una meta
o un sueño que dejamos en un cajón al
lado de la mesa por pensar que es tan
grande que nos rebasa yo no puedo yo
jamás eso no es para mí
vamos a quitar esas barreras y todos
esos sueños tan grandes se pueden
alcanzar de una manera
segmentando ese sueño tan grande para
convertirlo en una meta los segmentamos
lo partimos en cachitos que serían
objetivos a corto plazo voy alcanzando
los objetivos y eventualmente en esta
escalinata de objetivos cumplidos
alcanzaré el sueño más grande de mi vida
por supuesto requiere de sacrificios
habrá muchísimo trabajo y esfuerzo en el
camino se vale detenerse se vale ver el
panorama se vale llorar se vale llorar a
las 12 de la noche con tu mamá en una
videollamada no lo digo yo me contaron
pero siempre manteniendo en la mente una
idea muy importante darlo todo esperando
el resultado perdón
dándolo todo y esperar obviamente el
resultado deseado
en fin todos todos nosotros estamos
mucho más cerca del éxito de lo que
creemos muchas gracias
bueno ahora para
para continuar y con lo que me pongo
nervioso
este voy a presentar un cuadro que
celebra nuestro hermoso folklore
tamaulipeco dirigido coreografiado
ensayado pensado por el maestro
alejandro villasana está por allá
es director general
[Aplausos]
director general del ensamble folklórico
teocalli de aquí de la ciudad de nuevo
laredo y doy la bienvenida al escenario
a mi hermosa pareja
la increíble bailarina vivian valladares
era más que chulada
en casa
muchas gracias vivian talentoso local y
bueno muchísimas gracias espero que les
guste
[Música]
sí
i
[Música]
d
a mí
para mí
[Música]
con todo
pero no
[Música]
bien
está bien
aquí
[Música]
r
porque aquí
[Música]